JoJosé Legaut, Alec Castonguay,
StStéphanie Grandmont bonsoir.
J'J'ai une petite hésitation.
QuQu'est-ce qui ressort du rappt
dede la commissaire à l la sant.
MaManque de main-d'oeuvre,
gogouvernance défaillante,
peperception d'un manque
d'd'indépendance à l la Santé
pupublique, accès s aux données
dédéficientes, donc ne pas savor
ququi a quoi. On voit un certain
nonombre de résumés mais ce que
j'j'ai retenu, la phrase, c'est:
lele leadership était insuffisat
etet on parle du leadership au
gogouvernement aussi et qu'il ny
avavait pas de lentilles aînéné.
CoComme si on avait pas été
cacapable de voir ce qu'on aurat
ddû v voir, c'est-à-d-dire les
pepersonnes âgégées couraient un
ririsque énorme. C'est Maurice.
JoJoséeé.
- - C'est un excellent résumé, l
fafaut le dire. C'est sûr r que
c'c'est un rapport qui nous laie
unun peu sur notre faim, rappors
bubureaucratiques qui ne voient
papas du tout non plus
prprofondément dans la chaînenee
cocommandement, contrairement àe
quque dit la commissaire à l la
sasanté, ça milite encore plus
popour une commission d'enquêtee
inindépendante. Mais la lentille
popour les aînénés,
onon sait qu'elle était tout à
fafait absente. 64 % des décès u
QuQuébec pendant la premièrere e
ététaient des personnes résidant
sosoient en CHSLD, en ressources
inintermédiaires ou en ressourcs
popour aînénés.
C'C'est énorme sur à p peu près0
pepersonnes. C'est pour ça qu'on
ututilise le terme hécatombe et
c'c'est beaucoup plus élevé que
dadans le reste du Canada
prproportionnellement parlant.
MaMais pour le reste, oui, la
SaSanté publique, c'est
inintéressant qu'elle le note, e
mamanque d'indépendance. Le
didirecteur national de la Santé
pupublique, qu'il s'appelle
HoHoracio Arruda ou Luc Boileaue
fafait mêmeme par rapport aux ps
d'd'opposition donc imaginer au
rereste de la population. Ça
auaurait pu jouer un rôlele. C't
unun élément parmi tant d'autre.
- - Pour donner le contact, quad
MoMonsieur Legault se faisait
ququestionner sur la tenue d'une
enenquêtete publique indépendan,
ilil disait que la commissaire à
lala santé, on la connaît t et e
a a tous les pouvoirs et elle va
fafaire le travail. Avez-vous
l'l'impression qu'elle a fait ue
grgrosse partie du travail?
- - Je pense que cela s'ajoute u
trtravail fait en mêmeme temps t
quque ça commence à c concorders
mamal. Le résumé que vous en avz
fafait, Patrice, c'est qu'il n'a
papas pas beaucoup de choses
susurprenantes parce que la
prprotectrice du citoyen est
ararrivée à p peu près s aux mês
coconclusions. La coronaire n'a
papas encore remis son rapport
mamais on entendu dans ses
auaudiences des choses qui vont
exexactement dans le mêmeme sene
JoJohanne Castonguay. On est reu
àà 2 2 enquêtetes ou 3 qui ont
dodocumenté cette crise dans les
CHCHSLD et c'est pas mal tout le
tetemps la mêmeme affaire intert
: : on était pas préparée,
prprévention contrôlele
dédésinfection, contrôlele, toue
quque vous avez dit est vrai.
D'D'abord, ce rapport et le clou
dadans le cercueil de la version
dede Danielle McCann.
IlIl y a beaucoup de témoins qui
didisent : on n'a pas averti les
CHCHSLD à l la fin du mois de
jajanvier, on a rien fait avanta
fifin mars pour que les CHSLD
sosoient prêtsts donc ça, au mo,
onon éclaircisse et on sait qu'l
a a exagéré devant GM Kamel et e
n'n'est pas Marguerite Blais.
IlIl y a tellement de rapports i
n'n'ont pas été mis en applicatn
auau fil des 20 et 30 dernièrers
anannées parce que c'est presque
unun échec collectif pararce qun
n'n'a pas mis en place les mesus
ququ'on devait mettre en place.
- - Comment vous résumez ça c'et
ququelqu'un vous demande : pis?
- - C'est sûr r que c'est la pre
ququ'on n'était pas prêt.t. On e
vovoit de par les chiffres. Au
lilieu de tirer les leçons de la
crcrise de H1N1 qui avait eu l u
1010 ans plus tôt t en ce prépat
plplutôt,t, on a fait l'inversea
cocommencé au Québec à i investe
momoins en moins enfanté publiq.
LeLe Québec est la province où n
a a investi le moins par rapporà
l'l'ensemble de nos dépenses en
sasanté donc seulement 2 %. Tous
leles autres provinces en mettet
plplus et nous sommes la seule
prprovince aussi où cette peur
papardon, cette part accordée àa
SaSanté publique a diminué depus
1010 ans. La différence est énoe
paparce qu'ici, per capita, ça
dodonne 118 $ alors qu'au Canad,
onon est plutôt t autourur de 3t
dadans les pays de l'OCDE, c'est
20200 $ donc ça fait une grosse
didifférence. Donc quand on voit
HoHoracio Arruda qui quitte et
lalaisse le gouvernail à
ququelqu'un, on peut se dire :
d'd'accord et c'est peut-êtrtree
nanavire sur lequel il voguait
ququ'il a besoin d'êtrtre retapé
dadans son ensemble.
- - De donner un coup de barre.
AÀ la question : croyez-vous
nénéanmoins qu'on a besoin d'un
exexercice, un autre, une enquêe
pupublique, voici sa réponse.
JOANNE CASTONGUAY, commissaire à
lala santé et au bien-êtrtre, Qc
- - Honnêtetement, je pense qu'e
lele rapport de la protectrice
dudu citoyen, le rapport
àà v venir du coroner et
nonos rapports, on a tout
cece qu'il faut pour s'engager
dadans une transformation
etet regarder vers l'avenir.
IlIl est vraiment temps
ququ'on passe à l l'amélioration
dede notre systèmeme de santé pr
fafaire face aux crises futures,
mamais aussi pour améliorer
sasa performance en tout temps.
- - Tour de table rapide là--
dedessus. Qu'en pensez-vous de a
réréponse.
- - Oui, c'est bien qu'on commee
àà a avoir de plus en plus de de
gegens qui témoignent en disant:
cece n'est pas nécessaire. C'est
vrvrai que l'ampleur de la crise
didictée d'avoir une réponse
imimportante est de faire le tor
dede la question ne serait-ce qe
papar respect pour les gens qui
sosont décédés, maintenant, c'et
vrvrai qu'on a de plus en plus
enenquêtete qu'il en vienne mete
totous les morceaux du puzzle ax
bobons endroits et que si on
fafaisait une commission, ça
momobiliserait tout le systèmeme
santé peut-êtrtre 2 ans plus,
sasait-on jamais. Mais ce n'est
papas comme ça qu'on irait de
l'l'avant.
- - Vous vous rangez, vous, vers
cecette opinion. - Je trouve que
c'c'est de plus en plus déchira.
- - Moi, je suis d'accord avec
MaMadame Castonguay. Je fais pai
dedes sceptiques depuis un bon
momoment parce que si on fait ue
enenquêtete publique, c'est pour
cocomprendre les mécanismes et n
papas pour trouver des coupable.
QuQu'on améliore la situation. e
pepense qu'avec le rapport de
MaMadame Castonguay et le rappot
dede la protectrice du citoyen,
totout ce qui a été écrit, on a
ququand mêmeme pas mal compris e
ququi doit êtrtre amélioré et
chchangé. Si on veut une enquête
pupublique parce qu'on veut
trtrouver des coupables, c'est e
auautre chose. Les partis
d'd'opposition aimeraient ça et
leles médias aussi. Mais si
l'l'objectif est de modifier le
réréseau de la santé pour que ls
CHCHSLD soit mieux équipé, si
c'c'est ça l'objectif, je pense
leles réponses.
- - Je vais êtrtre obligé d'être
d'd'un autre avis justement.
JuJustement parce que je fais à
pepeu près s 25 mêmeme je dirai0
anans au Québec qu'on a eu plein
dede rapports et de mémoire
dédéposé, des alertes ont été
sosonnés à r répétition concernt
leles CHSLD et tout ce matériel
esest atterri au mêmeme endroits
unune vaste déchiqueté 2 dans ls
ououbliettes du Parlement, je ne
sasais où je crains que celui de
MaMadame Castonguay va aller aui
leles rejoindre. Et c'est pour a
quque ça prend une vraie
cocommission d'enquêtete
inindépendante pour qu'on ailleu
fofond des choses et ce n'est ps
unune question de trouver des
cocoupables mais il y a une
imimputabilité des décideurs eti
j'j'étais né parti d'opposition,
jeje ferai attention aussi parce
quque ça va les appeler des
lilibéraux, ça va toucher les
pépéquistes parce que la
nénégligence des CHSLD en avant,
elelle date aussi de leur propre
gogouvernement mais c'est
imimportant qu'on le sachehe ete
dedernièrere chose, c'est seulet
unune commission d'enquêtete, ce
lala commissions parents sur la
DPDPJ qui peut justement produie
unun rapport en profondeur, des
rerecommandations précises et l,
onon peut faire le suivi ensuit.
EsEst-ce que ces recommandations
sosont vraiment adaptées ou non.
SiSinon, on se retrouve avec une
cocourtepointe de toutes sortese
rarapports de gouvernementale
BeBeaujeu de les ignorer.
- - Là, , c'est moi... je vais e
obobligé d'êtrtre en désaccord,
j'j'entends depuis ce matin :
lulumièrere jaune, attention, ls
sosondages, Monsieur Legault a
babaissé. C'est drôlele, mais si
j'j'étais dans votre siègege, je
susuis pas, mais je vous écoute,
jeje trouve que c'est bon. On va
momontrer le sondage en questio.
InIntentions de vote publié ce
mamatin. Il n'a perdu que 4 pois
dede pourcentage. C'est mon
ininterprétation. Ce n'est pas
bebeaucoup. Madame Anglade, aucn
gagain. Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois, n
popoint de pourcentage, Éric
DuDuhaime, 6 points de pourcente
etet les parties québécois qui
popoursuit sa descente. On a
mimis tous les chiffres.
IlIl y a égalité. Moi, si je sus
MoMonsieur Legault, je regarde a
etet je me dis : comment ça se
fafait que je n'ai pas plus baié
cocompte tenu de la grogne des
memesures en janvier, les mesurs
sasanitaires. Je ne vois pas
bebeaucoup de lumièrere jaune.
- - J'imagine Monsieur Legault
êêtrtre soulagé. En effet. On et
ququand mêmeme plusieurs mois ee
l'l'élection. Après s 22 mois de
papandémie, l'hécatombe de la
prpremièrere vague et la gestion
chchaotique de la 5e vague dans
lalaquelle on se trouve en ce
momoment, sa popularité reste
ququand mêmeme très s forte.
N'N'oublions pas que la CAQ a éé
élélu en 2018 avec 47 % des voix
dodonc moins encore que ce qu'ia
totoujours et son avantage poure
momoment, c'est non seulement la
didivision des partis
d'd'opposition. Les partis
d'd'opposition Québec se
rereproduisent comme des lapins.
OnOn est rendu avec les partiesu
coconservateurs du Québec qui
momonte et qui talonne le PQ etS
etet tout le monde et, pour lui
c'c'est à s son avantage. Je nes
papas sûr r que c'est un avantae
popour la démocratie au Québec r
cocontre parce que ça fait des
opoppositions faibles et
frfragmentées. C'est de la
babalkanisation finalement. J'ai
ututilisé un vieux mot de sciene
popolitique, mais vous avez touà
fafait raison, je pense qu'il ny
a a pas... il y a une petite
dedescente, mais il n'y a pas..-
ilil n'y aurait pas eu de descee
ququ'on serait sur Mars. On aurt
didit : bien voyons donc, ça nee
pepeut pas qu'il n'y ait pas de
dedescente.
- - Voilà, , la lumièrere et jae
ppâlele parce qu'il y a plusieus
sosondages qui montrent une
dedescente. Ce sondage est trèss
sesemblable à c celui du magazie
l'l'actualité. On concorde chez
leles maisons de sondage s'en et
papas tout à f fait d'accord sur
l'l'emploi de la baisse, on a ue
babaisse. Mais dans les 2 cas, n
vovoit que les libéraux n'en
prprofitent pas. Québec solidaie
prprofite un peu mais les libérx
etet les péquistes ne profitent
papas de ce qui se produit et ls
plplus petits partis en profite
mamais ils partent de tellement
loloin qu'ils en profitent dans
unune moindre mesure. Je suis
d'd'accord avec tout ce que Josa
didit. C'est un scénario parfait
popour François Legault de
didivision de l'opposition et
susurtout quand on regarde chez
leles francophones, ceux qui
susuivent Monsieur Legault, c'et
QuQuébec solidaire à 1 14 %, çat
didire qu'à l l'extérieur des cs
dede Laval et certains comtés de
MoMontréal, c'est un massacre.
--
SiSi les libéraux avaient pris 4
ouou 5 points de pourcentage,
QuQuébec solidaire 2 ou 3 points
dede pourcentage, on avait une
tetendance ou l'opposition... ms
EÉric Duhaime aussi tu, on peut
didire que cette momentanée, c't
lala campagne
- - ça ressemble un peu à u un i
réréférendum sur les mesures
sasanitaires. Envoi la CAQ qui
peperd un peu de plume parce que
leles gens en ont ras le pompont
fifinalement, c'est Éric Duhaime
etet le parti conservateur qui a
rérécupérer toutes les personnes
ququi grognent contre les mesurs
sasanitaires. Sa le portrait. Ms
enen réalité, la CAQ partait de
tetellement haut. Avant Noël, on
leleur donnait pratiquement sans
dédéputés à l la prochaine élec.
C'C'était les 3/4 des
cicirconscriptions. On n'a pas u
çaça depuis les années 80 depuis
l'l'élection de Robert Bourassa
dodonc c'est quand mêmeme énorm.
DoDonc qu'ils perdent un peu de
plplume, ça va faire plaisir
MoMonsieur Legault parce que
d'd'abord, qu'aucune reçu
nonombreux, ça fait beaucoup de
susurveillance à f faire. Peut-e
quque finalement...
- - C'est intéressant parce que
c'c'est l'analyse... à l la mode
ququ'au Bye Bye,... pardon, Jea-
FrFrançois Lisée avait une bonne
liligne, il disait : si Monsieur
LeLegault ne veut pas avoir une
écécrasante majorité de députés,
ilil n'a qu'à s signer son inten
dede faire une proportionnelle,e
ququ'il ne veut pas faire. Ça ne
sese fera pas.
- - Il ne le fera pas plus que s
auautres. Mais ceci étend dit, l
esest quand mêmeme là e et il et
jujustement sur la question de a
gegestion d'pandémie. Et ce que
cecela dit Monsieur Legault et e
nene sais pas s'il va suivre cet
avavis, mais ce que cela dit à
MoMonsieur Legault, c'est qu'il
dodoit absolument redresser son
gogouvernail pour la 5e vague,
acaccord de meilleure
cocommunication et que ces mesus
sosoient plus claires.
- - Voici le rapport de Madame
CaCastonguay. Je ne sais pas sin
pepeut le mettre. Pardon, on vae
memettre au retour de la pause